eu tenho uma mensagem que pode ser
assustadora e ao mesmo tempo fascinante
para compartilhar com vocês
é uma mensagem sobre jovens jovens como
praia tem 16 anos e é filho de uma
professora auxiliar jovem como isabeli
que mora com seus avós ou até como
pequeno élvio que adora tirar boas notas
no colégio
por enquanto nenhum desses jovens têm
uma identidade própria
são pequenos indivíduos com grandes
chances de crescer em e repetirem
antigas fórmulas do passado estão sendo
educados como há 100 anos atrás mas para
viverem no mundo de hoje onde novas
tecnologias e novas profissões estão
sendo criadas a cada instante
em comum além desses três jovens viverem
no interior do estado do rio de janeiro
eles têm um enorme desafio pela frente
todos eles estão diante do futuro
incerto e repleto de transformações
segundo futurista americano thomas frei
60% das profissões dos próximos dez anos
ainda não foram inventadas e é incrível
o que as consultorias internacionais
sugerem como profissões que os próximos
anos muito em breve teremos juntos nós
um arquivista pessoal que vai ser
responsável por organizar e catalogar
toda a informação que você gera ao longo
de toda sua vida
teremos também o tutor de criatividade
que vai ser responsável por que oferecer
conteúdo de inspiração para que você
ingere novas perguntas e trilhar novos
caminhos e ainda teremos entre nós diz o
organizador corporativo que vai ser
responsável por limpar a hierarquia das
empresas para criar a cultura de estar
tatu através do caos organizado pois é
alguém ainda duvida que o futuro vai nos
trazer muitas surpresas
às vezes eu fico um pouco assustado com
a velocidade que o mundo vem se
transformando em certeza aliás que os
meus pais já estão apavorados há muito
tempo mas as perguntas que surgem são
como você acha que vai ser o futuro do
brian da isabella e do pequeno élvio
diante de um cenário tão complexa como é
que vai ser crescer e viver no olho de
uma revolução onde as realidades podem
se transformar cada minuto e mais seu
filho tá preparado para isso
essas perguntas começaram a bombardear
minha mente com mais intensidade a
aproximadamente 11 anos atrás na época
em que nasceu ana helena a minha filha
ea minha inspiração
quando os nossos filhos
começamos a enxergar o mundo com outros
olhos é uma sensação louca primitiva
ancestral se você tem filhos sabe do que
estou falando
se você não tem filhos pode ter certeza
você vai saber que a sensação é essa
para quem tem neto talvez saiba disso em
dobro a verdade é que filho não vem com
manual de instrução
recebemos um pacote combo na maternidade
recebemos um toque de amor infinito
a gente começa a perceber detalhes que
antes eram ignorados problemas que antes
eram distantes do planeta fica com medo
impacto da tecnologia na sociedade e até
mesmo a qualidade da camada de ozônio
essas preocupações representa a nossa
responsabilidade de preservar nossa
espécie representa o nosso dever de
defender os nossos herdeiros quando
nascem os nossos filhos
passamos a temer por todos os problemas
da humanidade
aliás
quando nascem os nossos filhos passamos
a temer pela própria humanidade e antes
de continuar preciso confessar uma coisa
pra vocês se eu estou aqui hoje
compartilham dessas idéias é por causa
do amor que eu sinto pelos meus filhos
mas também e principalmente por causa do
medo mas eu não me envergonho desse medo
muito muito pelo contrário esse medo me
dá forças
esse medo da energia para uma luta que
merece ser travada
eu não sou educador eu não sou pedagoga
mas nos últimos anos eu tive o
privilégio de participar de projetos
incríveis diretamente relacionados à
causa educacional
eu percebi muito rapidamente que a
educação é a chave para preparar os
nossos filhos para o futuro mas também
um caminho para que os mais jovens
possam construir um novo mundo mais
responsável mais humano mais holístico
um mundo mais viável
a maioria das pessoas acham que precisam
de um mundo melhor os seus filhos mas na
realidade precisamos de filhos melhores
para o mundo essa situação que carlos
slim reforça totalmente a minha aposta
nas gerações futuras mas não é nada
fácil
apesar de todo o desenvolvimento dos
novos arranjos sociais que vem se
desenhando
apesar de todo avanço tecnológico que a
gente está vivendo
apesar das crianças já nascem conectadas
e manuseando tablets
apesar de estarmos em plena era do
conhecimento
a nossa educação ainda se mantém nos
velhos modelos industriais
as nossas escolas e sua esmagadora
maioria ainda se organiza no formato de
série o que denota uma produção serial
como uma linha de montagem onde então
pequenos indivíduos com suas
características próprias e saem pessoas
formatadas sem as suas individualidades
prontas para viver no mundo supostamente
linear
esse modelo realmente funcionou por
muitos e muitos anos
e realmente garantiu a nossa
sobrevivência por esses anos mas o mundo
mudou
hoje a gente está vivendo a revolução
digital que vivemos novas necessidades
novas realidades e o mais incrível disso
é que não existem culpados para esse
cenário
eu não conheço um educador se quer que
esteja satisfeito com os modelos
contemporâneos de educação
o educador seja através do professor do
gestor escolar ou até do agente do poder
público traz consigo a nobre missão de
adaptação aos novos tempos
no entanto existe uma inércia tão
poderosa que impede que os modelos
educacionais se mantenham em linha com a
nova sociedade
essas forças nos mantém atrelado aos
velhos modelos industriais
este anúncio de jornal publicada em 2014
mostra um exemplo disso que ainda nos
dias de hoje
a nossa educação sofre uma fortíssima
influência do modelo industrial
as semelhanças não param por aí
por exemplo seu filho ainda usa uniforme
nos dias de hoje como uma fábrica
o seu filho ainda tem chamado de
campainha para início e fim de turno
como uma fábrica mas como eu disse
o mundo mudou chega uma hora que a gente
precisa parar de falar e começar a agir
nessas horas tudo que a gente mais quer
é construir um novo futuro dos nossos
filhos e assim eu comecei
mas quem seria eu diante de gigantes
educadores que encontraram enorme
resistência e chegaram a morrer luta
quem seria eu
um designer complexo
bom eu sou designer e não desisto nunca
quem é designer e deve entender nós
temos à nossa disposição uma das mais
poderosas ferramentas para resolução de
problemas e transformação de realidade
temos a nosso favor um poderoso valioso
processo para criar novos futuros
a partir de então eu tinha mais
esperança e designer como aliada
aliás eu tinha mais do que o design
design thinking aquela metodologia
flexível que permite que a gente consiga
desenhar soluções para as necessidades
das pessoas do século 21 que a gente
possa criar unidades de transformação
que cria um novo futuro seja a mudança
que eu acredito
acredito que a mudança vem de dentro de
cada um de nós mas para que ela seja
mais efetiva a gente ainda precisa fazer
um novo trabalho de base
sim precisamos plantar novas árvores que
têm novos frutos recursos para construir
o futuro
antes é preciso mais jovens que eles têm
toda a capacidade para a construção de
uma nova responsabilidade coletiva
temos que mostrar para os jovens que
todos nós juntos somos capazes de criar
uma nova humanidade uma nova sociedade
mais simpática
a partir desse momento a gente pode
começar a enxergar o mundo através das
lentes da abundância para ajudar nessa
missão
começamos a enxergar o cenário temos um
propósito e um desafio muito relevante
temos vontade e temos ferramentas
poderosas mas a gente não pode é o
famoso tenista americano e é reconhecido
pela sua superação no meio do esporte
onde você está
use o que você tem e faça o quê
você pode eu me inspirei nessa frase
e foi exatamente isso que eu fiz
influenciado pelas metodologias ágeis
que eu tanto estudava o design design
link eu coloquei na cabeça que eu
precisava criar um produto mínimo viável
que gerasse uma pequena curva de
aprendizagem inicial mas que me desse
recurso para novos ciclos de
desenvolvimento
a essa altura eu não tinha a menor
dúvida
ana helena minha filha seria o primeiro
protótipo que viria ser um projecto
muito ambicioso
helena desde pequena minha rotina
profissional nos meus projetos pessoais
sempre que possível colocar ela sentada
ao meu lado enquanto trabalhava
o pensamento e da criatividade trabalho
estimulei seu altruísmo e principalmente
a sua vontade trabalhando mas dessa vez
foi ela que positivamente na entrega na
ilustração de peixinho que estão
chegando agora
o toque final a gente fechar o arquivo
foi o pai porque a gente não faz sorrir
e todos os anos quando a gente vê esse
peixinho estampado num evento da nossa
cidade nosso coração se enche de alegria
e de orgulho
o tempo passou aumentamos a nossa
confiança e nosso senso de
responsabilidade
aprendemos e descobrimos muitas coisas
juntos
eu ia helena
a gente sentia que tinha muita energia
naquele processo
a gente sentia que existe é muito valor
para ser compartilhado ea gente queria
aumentar o raio de impacto no nosso
trabalho
a missão aumentava não bastava
apresentar o design thinking somente
para helena a gente precisava mostrar
isso para as próximas gerações
segundo gaian asna especialista em
criatividade criativa sobretudo otimista
porque se não houver a esperança em
criar algo novo e com base nesse
pensamento o nome do nosso projeto
surgiu de uma forma muito natural
acredite é preciso acreditar que tudo
vai dar certo
a ideia é uma interferência positiva e
prática na vida de jovens e adolescentes
e jovens que funciona como ferramentas
para que os jovens se tornem realidade
de seus sonhos e os seus projetos
o empreendedorismo
o incerto é isso que o projeto acredite
se propõe a entregar os jovens e eu
posso garantir que esse projeto está
demandando muita energia mas posso
garantir que ainda mais
cada gota de suor vale a pena porque não
existe alegria maior no mundo do que
você é arregaçar as mangas botar a mão
na massa e construir um futuro melhor
para os seus filhos pros seus netos e
gerações
o melhor disso tudo
o projeto acreditar sempre em ótima
companhia da minha filha ana helena
hoje em dia o projeto acredite é
realidade
acabamos de pública nós primeiro livro
orientando jovens e adolescentes nas
metodologias criativas do design
thinking
hoje em dia o projeto kit é realidade e
nós invadimos as escolas oferecendo
experiências de transformação através de
projetos reais
esse aqui é um exemplo de um projeto que
nasceu de um sonho
percorreu um processo de desenvolvimento
e chegou a uma solução possível
isso representa materializa uma
realidade projetada através do design e
para o design é uma realidade projetada
de pessoas para pessoas que hoje em dia
é um protagonista na sua escola e
desenvolve um projeto chamado cineclube
social onde olha eu ele oferece educação
cinematográfica aos jovens da rede
pública da sua localização
desenhado de pessoas para pessoas como
isabeli que hoje é líder de um grupo em
seu colégio onde está construindo uma
recicloteca para oferecer consciência
ambiental a pais alunos e professores e
pessoas como pequeno élvio que também no
seu colégio tal desenvolver um sistema
de captação da chuva para melhorar conta
de água da sua escola e ainda assim
ajudar o planeta
todos esses jovens agora tem uma
identidade mais forte
eles estão construindo com as suas
próprias mãos
o protagonismo tão importante no mundo
em transformação
eles estão construindo com as suas
próprias mãos um novo mundo e eu
gostaria de lembrar que o projeto
acredite que foi feito com pouco
conhecimento pouco recurso mas com muita
vontade é apenas uma trajetória possível
existem inúmeras outras
as possibilidades muitas delas
adormecidas dentro de você e para
finalizar eu deixo uma pergunta na
verdade uma provocação
o que você pode fazer agora para
construir um futuro melhor
vamos nessa